so it's July 18 Tuesday July 18 2017 and
I've been working for the last few days
on the 8th lecture in my series the
psychological significance of the
biblical stories and I'm planning to
talk about the Abrahamic stories that
immediately follow the stories of Noah
and the Tower of Babel I'm not as
familiar with Abrahamic stories as I am
with the stories the earlier stories in
Genesis say from the beginning of the
Bible through the stories of Noah and
the Tower of Babel and I'm not as
familiar with the Abrahamic stories as I
am with the stories of Moses that begin
with Exodus and continue in the
succeeding chapters so I've had to do a
lot of reading and a lot of thinking and
and some conversing as well and as part
of that process I spoke once again with
Jonathan Paola a Carver of stone icons
and an Orthodox Christian and student of
religion and also this time who I did a
video with a while back you might
remember called the metaphysics of Pepe
where we discussed the psychology of the
stranger and also some of the stories
gaybraham ik stories involving lot in
Sodom and Gomorrah and I also had the
opportunity to meet his brother Matthew
pazzo who's been working on a book on
the Bible for the last three and a half
years and so we spent 90 minutes talking
about the Abrahamic stories and the
conceptual background that's necessary
to understand them and that's what I
wanted to show you today after this
introduction so I hope it's useful so
I'm going to introduce both of you so
Jonathan is a carver of icons and I've
spoken with Jonathan a number of times
already and he now has his own YouTube
channel as well where he discusses
issues that are similar to the ones that
we're going to discuss today and Matthew
is his brother who I haven't met before
this day and Matthew has been working on
a book for the last how long you're not
here three and a half years and do you
want to tell everyone very briefly about
the book well it's a book about
symbolism but it is basically I'm trying
to rediscover the worldview that was
present in
the time of the Bible or at least
actually not that long ago because
modern modern interpretations of reality
materialist interpretations of reality
aren't that old
right the worldview that was there when
traditional societies were still there
and so I'm trying to rediscover that
worldview and basically there are basic
patterns have an inner time and space
things like things like that so it's
like a cosmology that's been completely
lost as far as I'm concern people have
glimpses of it I think a lot of people
do but it's very general patterns that
we have to re re understand so we can
understand the Bible for example in
other other societies so there are did
you get interested in this like what is
it that's compelled you to do this oh I
don't know where to start I mean my
whole life has been about that so I mean
you read the Bible you can take it
literally you can take it figuratively
or you can take it both ways and I'm
trying to take it both ways
I'm trying to get rid of that dichotomy
the dichotomy of symbolism and factual
description I think there is no such
htech otta me if you understand what the
words mean if you have the right
perspective there's no more metaphors in
the Bible there are none okay but it
takes a while to get there because you
have to adopt a completely different
perspective than a materialistic one
obviously it can be a materialist and
and a Christian or it can't be a
religious and immaterial that's what I
think okay and one of the things we're
hoping is that you know we've been
getting I've been getting a lot of
questions and I know you've probably
Jordan me getting a lot of questions
about this question of metaphor and a
lot of people have been asking me how do
we reconcile how do i reconcile
metaphors with what's in the Bible how
do i reconcile these metaphors with how
I'm supposed to live in the world and I
think that what Matthew has been rough
with is writing and what I've been I've
been reading it right I'm reading it
right now is that he he's really able to
answer that question in a way that I
think will be one of the most satisfying
answers that we've seen in a while so
we're pretty excited to see how
going to get that out to people so let
me start by telling you what I've been
thinking about just briefly and then you
guys can comment and I'd like you to do
most of the talking if we can manage
that although I'm so damn talkative it's
hard to imagine that will happen but so
I've been reading this book called the
disappearance of God and I've been using
it as a - by a guy named Richard
Friedman and it was published I think in
2005 I think that's right it might have
been earlier than that but he makes a
couple of interesting points about the
old abrading in the Old Testament and
and they're parallel points and so the
first is that the closer you are to the
beginning of the Bible the more God is
present and and as you progress towards
the end of the Old Testament God sort of
vanishes in stages until he only
manifests himself if at all in prophetic
visions and at the same time the
parallel development is that the stories
of individual human beings become more
and more well developed so it's like as
the idea of the individual personality
emerges or the fact of the individual
personality emerges to the presence of
God as a as a detectable entity like an
external entity even seems to decline
proportionately
and so I'm trying to puzzle that out in
a variety of different ways partly
neurologically because there's some
evidence that the domain of experience
that you might associate it with might
associate with the divine is a
consequence of suppressed lemmas left
hemisphere function and augmented right
hemisphere function and then I'm trying
to also consider that in relationship to
the effect of chemicals like psilocybin
which obviously can produce powerful
mystical experiences so experiences of
consciousness that are really of a
different type than normal waking ego
consciousness and I've also been reading
Jung's mostly commentaries about Jung's
red book and his attempts to
use active imagination as a as a means
to explore the contents of different
forms of consciousness which is
something that modern people just really
never do although he did it for years
and and the consequence of that was the
red book also the black books which
haven't been published yet but the red
book which was a which was I think
published two or three years ago it was
a collection of visionary experiences
and his his continuing discussions with
figures of his imagination which he
regarded as the most important work he
did in his life so so what's what does
that all boil down to it it's definitely
possible for people to have none can
happen to have experiences outside the
domain of their normal consciousness
that produce the intimation of the
divine that seems to be factually
indisputable those we're not exactly
sure how those experiences manifested
themselves in the periods of time that
are associated with the early biblical
stories the bit the Bible talks about
those sorts of experiences very
forthrightly in the earliest Abrahamic
stories and also in the story of Noah
and obviously in Adam and Eve and all of
that God's very present and then he
disappears over time and one of the
things that that the guy who wrote the
disappearance of God Freedman one of the
things he pointed out was that the fact
of the disappearance of God in the Old
Testament the fact that that's an air
that's a continual like it has narrative
continuity that fact he really remarked
on both those things because of course
the books were written by different
people and then they were aggregated but
out of that came two elements of
narrative continuity and one was the
gradual disappearance of God and the
other was the gradual rise of the
increasingly well-defined and powerful
individual so anyways associated with
that is the idea that as God withdraws
he also starts to manifest himself more
through the idea of a covenant
and that the Covenant is something
that's established with an individual
it's all obviously also with the nation
in the case of Israel but it's mediated
through individuals and so well that's a
brief wander through the sort of cloud
of associations that make up my thinking
about the topic at the moment so well
with what you described it sounds a lot
like what would you see in the Bible I'm
not so sure about the God is more
distant part where in further on and
goes from what I understand there are
two kinds of consciousness in the Bible
one of them is it's called inhabiting
the land that's when reality fits the
best of the theory okay so the
principles and the facts agree so there
are laws and people follow the laws okay
or there's an idea and reality fits with
that idea so that's called inhabiting
the land so it's familiar space okay so
when you live in that space things make
sense because your idea is match what's
happened free and then you can fall away
from that and that's the Covenant okay
covenant is an agreement between theory
and practice that's what a covenant is
in the Bible so God gives laws and the
people have to agree to follow basically
so the law is is is an identity it's not
just you do this you do that this it
expresses God's identity in practice so
when the facts match that identity
that's like a soul and a body that are
[Music]
not agree okay so when you fall away
from that you fall into exile that's the
other mode yeah and it looks like and
that's what you were talking about
before I'm not so sure until you talk
about a covenant but that's when the
meaning ends the facts do not match okay
so let me ask you a couple of questions
about that
yeah so you know I've been describing
the cosmology in the Bible as mapable
onto the domains of order and chaos and
I actually think the best way to define
order is order is the place you are when
what you're doing matches what's
happening yes very very very similar to
the idea that you just expressed and
then that's exactly it
okay okay and yeah that's a state
there's a state of harmony between
preconception and actuality and that's
also I think this the circumstances
under which people's emotions remain
regulated and I thought about that
neurologically too I think that what
happens is that under those conditions
you're left hemisphere stays in charge
and there's some evidence for that kind
of thing too especially from the
writings of this neurologist I think
he's a neurologist his name is Rama
Chandra he's quite a famous brain
scientist and he's oh and another
another neuropsychologist named
Belconnen Goldberg who's also talked
about hemispheric function in the same
way and so when things are going
according to plan
let's say yes you're in red and then the
individual ego consciousness that's
that's focused and specific stays in
charge but that also keeps negative
emotions regulated because there's no
need for them because everything is
working properly and so then you can
fall out of that and you called that you
call that exile not when you follow it
for me yeah yeah when you follow it by
the XS so that would be a quest all so
the flood it's also the slide yeah fine
okay so the exile is like the wandering
in the desert yeah oh it's the idea of
exile is it's exactly just what we said
it's about serving strange things so
you're not in charge anymore of relax
something else is but you're in you're
in that you live in in a world where
you're not in charge or your identity is
not in charge of the facts and they're
not they don't fit with reality so that
means something else is in charge and so
you're serving that so the idea of
serving strangers in exile
it simply means
absolutely your identity that match
reality oh that's really buddy I never
thought about that that idea of serving
strangers in exile so so okay so I'm
going to branch off that a couple of
different ways so one idea there is that
there's an idea from you which is
paraphrased something like if you don't
if you don't act out your own myth and
you serve a bit part in the myths of
others okay so that will be in keeping
with that idea of serving the stranger
in exile and then the next part would be
when you're in a chaotic state and your
emotions are dysregulated your
personality fraction aids and the
fractionated personality personality sub
personalities fight for control over
over over behavioral output so you
dissolve from a unity maite think about
it as a pyramid a pyramid with with a
unifying conception at the top that
disintegrates that would be like the
Tower of Babel to some degree that
disintegrates and then sub entities you
can think about them as spirits or think
about them as psychological entities
regulate your behavior and that would be
equivalent I think to a movement from
the left hemisphere to the right because
I think the right is dominated by
subcortical structures rather I think
that's how the animals exist is it's
sequential domination by subcortical
structures rather than some overarching
conceptualization from the top-down I
think that what you call the less than
the right is exactly the opposite of the
traditional left and right I'm not so
sure yet but when you say left
hemisphere what do you mean well like
what the left hemisphere governs the
right hand okay so the left hemisphere
is the one that went when it's in charge
and when everything works yes okay it's
the right oh it's exactly the opposite
of the traditional imagery usually it's
the right that's well yeah because
they're using the hands and I talked
yeah the brain Rock exactly so the right
that it's the right would be mapped onto
the left hemisphere okay so that's fine
that's fine and the traditional imagery
I think is associated with the
hemispheric specialization as well
because the idea of right
you know well I want to ask you a
question about that you said that they
the the living what was it you
contracted exile with what was the other
conceptualization and having the homely
inhabit inhabiting the homeland sure
absolutely
working on the home working on the
homeland is another way say okay now
tell me again how you conceptualize the
relationship between God and and his
people let's say in the homeland so that
well God like I said at the beginning
there's the idea of heaven in earth is
is at the basis of everything in the
Bible so heaven is meaning and earth is
fact so in that relationship there's God
it's always the name of God by the way
if you look if you look in the way it's
described in the Bible it's it's they're
talking about the name of God so that
means the meaning of God so God is not
just meaning but when they talked about
in the Bible it's always about the name
of God so the name of God is an identity
it's like a principal an axiom or
something like that and it has to embody
itself in physical reality flash or in a
matter so the the role of the nation of
Israel is to embody that identity and
it's also to embody it in reality not
just in themselves so basically they're
a mediator between heaven and earth
right they're trying to make God's
identity practical or concrete or that's
why it's all about laws because you take
and that's like mathematics you've taken
at an abstract principle that's really
extremely simple it doesn't seem like it
it contains much information right if
you take an axiom in mathematics but
then you have to derive all the
implications here so that's making it
practical that's making
concrete that's bringing heaven into the
earth so that's their job yeah it's like
a cosmic mediator okay Dean okay follow
you so far so all right so the the it
looks like there's two ways maybe in the
biblical narrative that that will is
instantiated in in reality and one would
be as a consequence of individuals
aligning themselves with the Word of God
and the other is the instantiation of
the Word of God into the State of Israel
okay
seem seem reasonable okay and that seems
to begin that that has its origin in the
in the first Abrahamic story
so Abraham talks to God and or God talks
to Abraham and tells him that he's going
to be the father of a nation essentially
and then it was to inherit the land to
do that important it's the same thing
those two things are the same he's going
to inherit the land and he's going to
become the principal of great many
people so that's like he's fleshing out
an identity right it gives a nation
instead of just an individual right and
he's going to be going to be identity of
a nation okay and so how do you
understand the description of that in
the in the biblical narrative because
one of the very one of the things I find
very strange about the Abrahamic stories
is that immediate presence of God and
God shows up to Abraham and tells him
this and then Abraham makes an altar if
I remember correctly once he gets to the
land where he's supposed to be he makes
an altar and then
and then God appears to him again yeah
not again not again
he appears to him the first time he
doesn't appear I think I'm pretty sure
the first time God speaks to him okay
he's active that's important okay let's
check inside not distinction important
well because he's just work he's just
yeah he's not physical he's not a into
practical reality yet it's invisible
so God speaks he's not manifest it's
just an idea of principle a word okay
and unmanifest word or it's like the
minimum of manifestation is like just
language this word and then so what he
says is go to this place go to this land
and you'll inherit the land and then he
goes there and then he says God appears
in our city so okay so there's a there's
a progression progressive in there's a
progressive appearance of God and it's
partly a consequence of Abraham's
original obedience to the initial idea
yeah which was very abstract means go
here you can't be more simple than that
go there so it's it's like it doesn't
mean anything but it means everything
it's a very everything we do is let's go
there go there and do something right
it's like principle of all things appear
to Abraham saying just go there and
you'll inherit that doesn't really mean
anything here but it contains everything
humans do yeah okay that that's an
interesting observation because you know
I think of human beings as well they're
very directional they're always going
from point A to point B they're always
aiming there like archers right and it's
definitely the case like I had someone
write to me know I was doing a patreon
interview with one of the people who've
been supporting me a young guy and we
were talking about the idea of Christ as
Redeemer and judge and he was this young
man was unredeemed let's say for
period of time because he didn't have
any direction and have direction you
have to know what's good and what isn't
because to have direction you have to go
to words what's good and so the judge is
what helps you figure out what's good
and if you don't know what's good then
you can't be redeemed because to be
redeemed is to be is to be moving
towards the good and away from let's say
evil so the judge and the Redeemer have
to be the same thing and that fits in
with what you're saying because the
judge is the thing that makes
qualitative distinctions let's say and
you need to make a qualitative
distinction before you can move ahead
okay and so your point is that the the
principle that Abraham encounters to
begin with is the principle of
directionality itself qualitative
directionality it's something like that
so that's right yeah it's well it's it's
the positive identity of anything like
it's it's like a seed it's like the seed
of a tree that's that's the traditional
way to understand it it's just a seed
yeah it contains everything in it but in
itself it's just something like go there
something go there okay so that's it
okay so one of the things that's been
interesting I think for me to learn
personally as I moved through my life
was that if I ever actually did anything
it was worthwhile yes you know what I
mean is that something would come of it
it wouldn't necessarily be what I
expected to come of it but yet act of
going and doing did bear fruit yeah and
that's pretty much the story of Abraham
in a nutshell
actually what he just said because God
says go here the only hair is the land
Abraham doesn't inherit the land I mean
he could have been right away you could
have gone there and it's yours right no
sir that's what it says as soon as you
gets there it says there's already
people there that the land is already
owned by other people
Grady's always a famine yeah exactly and
that means it means like what I was
saying before the facts supports the
theory
okay and here is going to the land
that's the theory you'll inherit that's
the theory and the facts don't support
it that's a--fun okay
the earth doesn't supply
the earth doesn't give you sustenance to
make it reality it doesn't give you
matter yeah give him a disease of in
Egypt and I mean his wife is separated
on a limb essentially a because he lies
about her but then it's so strange
because so he tells the Pharaoh and the
Pharaohs men that his wife is actually a
sister that's Soraya's Sarai
that how you say that yeah sir or she
changes the name yet yes it is actually
his sister and that's to protect them
and so the Pharaoh takes Sarai and then
okay going up they can I say something
you bet there's a meaning to all those
things as a meaning to it okay so the
idea is that when fact that fact support
the theory okay when when the flesh
supports the identity or the matters
haven't earth support seven things are
square okay that's just a traditional
way of understanding it that basically
means that what you see is what you get
okay it's it's true things are true
that's the definition of meaning matches
fact yes true okay fine when pragmatic
definition yeah when when the other side
happens then things are round there
they're cyclical okay and it essentially
it's time its space in time that's what
it is
okay one of them you're falling into
time things are not square that means
things do not the meaning doesn't match
the facts that's why it's all out lives
okay when they go into exile it's all
about lives it's all about screaming
okay because they're in that domain
they're in a domain where meaning in
fact doesn't match so everything happens
through lies interception and even the
whole idea of saying my wife is my
sister less that represents a cyclical
paradox
okay it was supposed to happen well why
cyclical your parent has a son and a
daughter
and they get married it's like a
regression okay it's like you're
producing different things and then
you're joining them back together and
I'm supposed to join them back together
because when you join them back together
it's like you're going you're regressing
when you rebuild something you start on
principle and you develop it take you
make specializations of that principle
when you start to mix them up again it's
like a regression you're going back to
something more primitive than before
okay now essentially that how do you see
that in relationship to Abraham's
insistence that Sarai is his is his
distant sister yeah because you're not
supposed to marry your sister and I'm
not saying that as a moralistic thing
even though it becomes one but the
reason you shouldn't marry your sister
is because you're undoing the work the
specializations that your your your
father or your mother have created it's
like going back
it's like regressing so like if you
marry your your father or your mother or
depending at your going back it's a
cycle you're not smoking that because
it's like you're annihilating something
that was specified okay look I'll give
you an example like it's imagery of that
that's pretty important in the sort of
the flood there are traditions that the
Giants created hybrids okay yeah one of
the things that Giants like to do is
create hybrids that they are either
themselves but they created hybrids they
took the species and they confuse them
back into who knows what okay and that's
very significant because it actually
means that you are regressing in a
confused manner okay that there is a
connection between the flood and what I
just said making hybrids and causing the
flood it's actually considered one of
the same thing
because I mean that makes some sense
yeah it's about returning to confusion
yep look look I'll say it this way
either names the animals Adam Adam name
gentleman's gating forgot asked Adams
and in Genesis first job in the universe
so he's asking is just specify different
things okay that are all I'll have the
same source right the same attitude yep
differentiate that the idea of
incarnated a principle into practice
damn please get differentiated okay now
if you reverse that process you're going
back to a more primitive level you're
going back to the flood because the
flood is the most primitive thing in in
that cosmology right it starts with a
flooded world that means everything's in
confusion so what you have to do is
specify things out but if you go back
there says okay so let me let me
reformulate that and tell you what
popped into mind
alright so God gives Abraham the word
and then Abraham follows it and God
manifests himself more completely to
Abraham and then what happens to Abraham
is twofold he ends up in a barren land
so nature rebels and he also ends up in
a tyranny right because he it's not only
not only does the land not produce so
it's in a famine but Egypt eventually
Egypt is generally speaking a symbol for
for tyranny throughout the initial parts
of the Old Testament I mean you see that
with the Pharaoh for example and and the
symbolism in in the mosaic story of the
of Egypt always being associated with
stone instead of water and so you could
say that God gives Abraham the command
to move forward but he has to contend
with the intransigence II of nature
which rejects him because there was a
famine and then he becomes subjugate
some become subject to both tyranny and
to deceit and so okay they see him oh
well this is there any are look okay
I'll say it this way it's it's more
about deceits and tearing okay
but the thing is when you're not in
charge
I mean desert here nice that's it when
you're you or whoever you identify with
is not in charge you're a slave to some
other principle right
you're embodying some other will that's
not you I mean that's theorem you're
right I mean so right and that said it's
really directly related to the idea of
hearing you're serving strangers break
it says it all well that also motivates
that also motivates Abraham's deception
right because he's terrified that the
strangers that he's serving will kill
him yet for his wife for his wife and
that's why he lied and he's afraid that
he's going to be treated very badly yes
because he doesn't want strangers to
have his wife okay his wife is like the
earth his wife is how he will incarnate
himself or express himself yeah in the
world
he's like the seed and the wife is like
feet above the earth something like that
so she some she is like his earth it's
like a miniature version of hadn't an
earth the male is heaven and the female
is the earth in that case that's the
whole idea he's not in charge of fact
anymore that includes his wife batting
dreams so he doesn't want other men
other principles to control his wife
right does that make sense
yes well it also it also seems to me
that because he's the land isn't
fruitful for him and because he's
serving strangers in a strange land
he's also correct to be afraid for the
loss of his wife
yes and how does he get out of it by
being deceitful because yes he's in the
cycle he's in that I mean are you
supposed to be truthful with your
adversary usually no especially when
you're adversaries hostile and if you're
an enemy territory your morality changes
because all of a sudden
it's not about being truthful it's about
surviving it's about it's like the most
primitive existence there is right the
more primitive state of existence are
more about species than about truth yeah
it's an advance it's an advanced state
to talk about truth it's when we all
agree you know we all agree on at least
something but before that is every man
or woman for him or herself it's all
about the seat
it's almost survival okay okay so now
now the next thing that happens
essentially is that the Pharaoh gets
plagued and he's wondering why so
because so the story indicates that the
Pharaoh has broken some natural law
let's say or some divine law and things
go very badly for him and then he
discovers I don't remember how he
discovers that he's taken suraíh sir I
think it doesn't say how yeah I think
that's right and and he discovers that
he's taken Sarah but that Sarah is
Abraham's wife and so then the Pharaoh
gives Abraham all sorts of goods and
yeah enzym on his way okay so that's
also quite confusing so abraham is
rewarded for is to see a sense
ill-gotten good yeah right
ile des good yeah Barto story sorry that
it's raining because you also see I
think did not account some of the
complexity that's embedded in the in the
Old Testament accounts is that it's not
a simple morality tale it - stretch of
the imagination especially see that in
the Abrahamic accounts because it's
Jacob who who's so deceitful with Esau I
mean he thought comes off I mean he has
kind of he's kind of unconscious he saw
yeah he gives things up too easily he's
too easily deceived and he's a bit
primitive it too primitive in a bit too
naive something like that
but Jacob places and Rachel plays some
really nasty tricks on him and yet they
come out ahead
yeah and so that's also a very difficult
thing to contend with well there's
there's this idea at least
in traditional interpretation there's
this idea that in Esau is actually
supposed to be that the king he should
be the only reason he isn't is because
there's something wrong that pretty much
described the whole Bible in its
entirety that there's there's the theory
in the fact the fact is supposed to be
king okay do you know what I mean by
that like I matter is king that's what
it's supposed to be but it's not and the
whole all the stories are about
redeeming redeeming that problem taking
care of that problem like the fact don't
match the theory we have to redeem the
facts that's that pretty much all the
stories in the Bible are about that and
that pretty much what's lost represents
in the story of Abraham as well okay he
represents the material reality he
represents facts but there's something
wrong with it let's go into the large
story now so okay so Abraham leaves and
I believe he leaves with lot and and law
it also becomes quite wealthy and they
go back to where Abraham had built the
altar initially but lot Lots men and
Abraham's men started to fight yeah so
they decide they're going to separate
and they basically do that somewhat
arbitrarily it could have gone either
way but lot ends up going to sort them
well actually there's something you
should be aware of well that's that's
the thing a lot of the stories in the
Bible are based on a really ancient way
of thinking that we don't really follow
anymore but I mean in the Bible there is
a reason why the directions of the
travels that they're not just random
like Egypt represents the earth and
what's the name of the city what's the
name of the place above her amethy the
place where he goes to meet
Laban eyes in the north okay I'm not
sure I remember the name of this see I
think it's Iran that represents heaven
okay and there's a reason it's not just
arbitrary it's because Egypt is south
and South is going down right we still
say that when you say that someone's
gone south we say that means that
they've gone to cedar they've gone down
yes so so in the Bible and especially in
Genesis especially in Genesis the South
represents the earth and the North
represents the heavens okay and like I
said it's not arbitrary it corresponds
to the geography of the region one of
them goes up hills the other one goes
downhill and the north is mountains like
snowy mountains and in the south there's
a Egypt which is like the low a low
place and summary to North literally is
up yeah it's not a metaphor yeah
it literally is close going getting
closer to heaven and the other ones
going into the earth so when they go in
exile into Egypt there it's actually me
they're going into the earth it's like a
defense in two years so it's like a
death its death right and they say it a
few times in the book of Genesis they
talk about your it's like dying going it
going to Egypt is like a death okay so
then now so then we moved to the story
of the strangers right wait nothing
you're going to say why the separation
of the land with lot and an Abraham oh
yes right the idea is that lot takes the
the south right and then a ramp oh yeah
that was the whole point of that yes a
lot there's a reason why he takes the
south it's the lowest place on earth
Sodom and Gomorrah that that place it's
the lowest place okay so literally the
lowest place on earth
right I'm not sure I don't know I don't
know I think that region actually is the
lowest place on earth but in the story
that that's how that's what it means it
means it's the lowest place you can go
so it's a place that's farthest away
from heaven yeah it's all in order
you're like the
idea that milton develops with regards
to satan when he's thrown from heaven
because the hell that satan inhabits is
the furthest possible away from heaven
that's got to find essentially okay
that's like a journey into fear yes it's
the same as it means the same thing as
falling asleep exile and sleep are the
same in the Bible sleep it'll kick this
form of Exile okay so it is so so the
next thing that happens is that we get
the first warning about Sodom and
Gomorrah yes that's just a very brief
sentence it's like a foreshadowing and
then the next thing that happens is that
there's an episode where there is a war
among kings and the kings if I remember
correctly it's the king of Sodom takes
lot and Abraham has to go rescue him and
he'd actually actually I think it's the
other way around
I think it's Kings from the north that
come down and take Sodom and Gomorrah
and a lot as part of that and so is the
king the king of Sodom and Gomorrah they
have to flee that's what I remember okay
do they flee with do they flee with what
no law is taken by these chains from the
north and the king of Sodom yeah I think
hives or something like that please
and then Abraham the King the king of
Sodom at the end give gifts to Abraham
to thank him that he today rescued him
yes that's right so what happens is that
yeah it says it came to pass in the days
of amraphel king of shinar etc that
these made war with bera king of sodom
and with persia king of gomorrah etc and
these were all joined together in the
Vale of Siddim which is in the Salton
Sea which is the salt sea so I presume
that would be the Dead Sea and that
would be that identity the low point
that you're describing those actual
earth is the Dead Sea yes pretty
interesting yeah and the Vale of Siddim
was full of slime pits and the kings of
Sodom and Gomorrah
and fell there and they took away all
the goods of sodom and gomorrah and all
their victuals and they took lot Abrams
brothers son who deltas who dwelt in
Sodom and his Goods and departed so you
can really see this whole geography did
Matthew talking about when they say that
Sodom and Gomorrah they had to flee and
fall into slime pits it's almost like
they're laying it out for us that they
had to almost kind of go even further
down into the earth to hide from these
these these invaders of the north that
are coming to take their their land so
ok so Abram goes in rescues lot and he
does that successfully and the and also
there's Kings that he that he frees as
far as I can tell yeah and probably then
the Kings want to reward him and Abraham
says to the king of Sodom that he
doesn't want any reward and the reason
he doesn't want any reward except for
what his men have eaten he doesn't want
any reward because I will not take
anything that is thine lest thou should
say I have made abram rich save only
that which the young men have eaten and
the portion of the men which went with
me and it looks see God has already
promised Abraham everything in some
sense and it looks like he doesn't want
to take anything and Abraham doesn't
want to take anything from anyone else
because what would it want to do would
it interfere with the purity of his
accomplishments something like that yeah
well III don't know for certain because
that's just a line I guess but in the in
the story in it it's not that much of a
big part of the story but the way I see
it is I think he says I don't want to
take even a shoe lash if you latch from
you ok so the reason why he said that
because the shoe is the lowest part is
the lowest clothing right it is not on
the feet so it's all related to the idea
that the earth needs to be redeemed
needs needs to be rectified and it's in
that situation it's not
like he's not allowed to accept a
certain thing is not eating the
forbidden fruit there are things in the
world that are poisonous to humans we
can't eat them because they don't agree
with our our patterns our mind so if you
eat poison you go into that place where
things don't agree your mind and your
body don't agree and if you if you if
you take if you drink alcohol that takes
you into the realm where your mind and
your body don't agree the theory doesn't
match the fact and then you go into that
whole confusion and so it could it be
that when when you don't have he doesn't
want to take from Sodom because Sodom is
already what we know Sodom to be I mean
it already represents kind of the land
it can't hold and will be burned off yes
it's something he can't he can't
integrate right something it's like
leather I said the forbidden fruit it
you don't want to eat you don't want to
accept matter that you can't handle that
you can't integrate so there's something
in that place that he doesn't know how
to deal with what to do with it and he
doesn't want his riches to come from
that place you didn't write these
that place yeah that would compromise
him because he doesn't know how to deal
with it yeah maybe someday you will
that's correct that's the whole idea and
actually here's an interpretation lot
represents that place that will one day
be redeemed okay the reason why they
talk about lot so much in the story of
Abraham is because he represents King
David but he is the ancestor of the
nation that will give rise to King David
okay it's like a secondary story within
the story but it's like a it's meant to
be interpreted in terms of a future
redemption of that place that he can't
handle that Abraham could not handle at
that time and that place will be
redeemed I'm giving you a lot of
tradition here
I happen this is what I quit I what I've
learned it's King David okay it's the
future King okay so the whole one area
vlog is about King David one and of
course Lauda is Abraham's descendants as
well because he's his nephew yes and so
Ibrahim is nephew descends into the
lowest place essentially yeah well look
it the story just starts out pretty
clear it starts out there's three sons
to Tara one of them is her on the other
ones Nahor and the other ones Abraham
okay Aaron dies that's how the story
starts okay that's like the beginning of
this story is Aaron dies and he has a
son called a lot see that's what I was
the idea is it's the same idea the son
of this Herrin he represents death he
represents the thing we can't handle he
represents the material facts that we
can explain with with our theories or
with our identity is the thing which is
the matter we can't handle
okay and that's why in story starts with
he dies the father of lots tax it means
lot represents some fact that we cannot
correctly integrate into our universe
this could be interpreted in so many
different levels but that's basically
what this I don't know if that makes
sense but the idea yeah I mean the idea
is that is the I think we need to see it
the idea that an orphan or a widow
that's what they always represent the DA
represents something that have lost
their their principle that unifies them
they're they're they're kind of various
connected from the hierarchy of the
family
so so so lot losing is the fact that
losing us father died means that he
loses the thing that gives him identity
and so he's like this he's like a piece
of Earth that his lost attachment or
lost meaning or well that that reminds
me of what happens to Noah's son
who sees him naked yeah right yeah and
and why they just because because to see
it seems to me I'm going to talk about
this a little bit tonight that to see no
one gets drunk and then which which Sun
is it
ham ham yeah really
first sees him but doesn't respond
properly the other sons when they see
Noah naked they cover him up and they
don't look and so it's like they're not
exposing their father's weakness his
mortality his is his insufficiency right
they had attained respect but but ham
doesn't do that but there's also more
what Matthew was talking about before
the in that story there's two things
that are implied of what Matthew was
talking about before this idea of wine
that brings you into this cycle where
causality ceases to be direct and then
what Pam told the fashion yeah and the
fact that hem sees his father naked he
discovers his nakedness is also a kind
of suggestion of incest as well the same
type the same type of inappropriate
causality that you be in the story of
the two of a Abraham's sister marrying
this writer right yeah and a lot with
his two daughters
yeah lot lot to daughter right so it's
transgression to give some fun
transgression against some fundamental
boundary yeah I guess the the
hierarchical relationship and of a
family right yes they're not supposed to
make loops focus it's a tree you're not
supposed to make loops in a tree so you
can say like that it's really simple and
that's supposed to regress and I
supposed to you produce things you're
not supposed to turn back on yourself
okay you're not supposed to go back
contradict ourselves okay so so maybe
that's why Lot's wife is turned into a
pillar of salt to she lay back right
yeah exactly yeah you have to do is
listen experimental and and and and
pines for something that that was
terrible they shouldn't be and so and
she's come out
not to look back once she once you
escape from that catastrophe you don't
get to be nostalgic for it the same
thing happens in the story of Moses
because what happens to the Israelites
when they're out in the desert is they
start to become nostalgic for Egypt for
the tyranny yet right and that's also I
think when God starts to send poisonous
snakes among them because right though
don't they they start to pine for Egypt
and complain about Moses and then they
start to worship other idols so that's
part of that confusion that you were
talking about and then God gets
irritated and throws a bunch of
poisonous snakes in there to give them a
good chomping yeah so I call that the
snakes come as a result of them wanting
to go back yeah yeah well right that
makes perfect sense so and you see that
nostalgia for tyranny you know you see
that the Soviet nor in Russia right now
in regards to Stalin and so the question
the question is I think this is one of
the things that the guy who wrote the
disappearance of God mentioned is do you
want to be well fed as a slave or hungry
and freedom something like that and the
choice well fed as a slave is not a good
choice yeah so okay now so in Jonathan
you and I had talked to fair bit about
the story of Abraham and the strangers
and before so so God decides to reward
Abraham and he tells him that just like
he told him before but he repeats it
that he's going to be the the founder of
the nation and he and he tells them that
Sarah is going to bear a child and Sarah
of course is not doesn't believe that
let's see let me let me just find this
here yeah
yes okay so that's what happens is the
is that God's God God's word comes in to
Abraham in a vision so it's the word
again saying that his reward will be
great and that he's going to be the
father of Nations but he doesn't have
any children and so isn't that when he
takes you take Farrah's servant Hagar
yeah and and that gives rise to Ishmael
and it isn't until later that Sarah is
informed that she's going sorry sir your
hopes up man turning the key one fancy
request this you want fancier quietly
I'd be curious to know what she has
found yeah you should look guys close
her down yeah I know it's very strange
intermission there so okay so so abraham
has to take a kind of a detour in order
to have a child and he lays with Hagar
and Hagar we don't know much about her
but she gets haughty right away and
starts to despise Sarai and Sarai
actually beats her as far as I can tell
it says Sarah dealt hardly with her and
then Hagar flees and she ends up by a
well where an angel appears to her and
the angel tells her that her son her
child is going to be the father of the
nation as well so so the first question
might be why is it that Abraham at this
point in the story why is it necessary
for the story that Abraham takes a
detour and has a child with Hagar what
do you think is a signifier it it's
always the same problem in the Bible
it's always it starts with confusion and
it has to develop towards something that
is clear
so you're saying it yourself when you
say detour yeah it's a detour exactly
that's exactly what it is it's a detour
okay that's not necessary but it happens
then they say well isn't there such as
these detours or if the others are
things that are not necessary but happen
there's something also in that detour
the fact that that he gives birth to
Ishmael which has to do with this this
turning because God kind of promises
that Ishmael is going to come back and
is going to be a big problem for you
he's going to be a father of a great
nation but it's going to be a big
problem for you later like this going to
be there's going to be fighting between
between your sons basically yeah there's
that idea yeah of course here you know I
don't know if it's in that story but
yeah well ASO seems to be associated
with an idea that you might think about
as successive approximation to an ideal
you know so one of the things that that
I conceptualize sort of visually is this
is associated with the idea of Geppetto
wishing on a star
you know so what Geppetto does when he
wants to facilitate the transformation
of Pinocchio is lift his eyes up to the
highest thing that he can conceive up
and Orient's himself with that but the
thing is is that as you move through
life let's say you're oriented by the
highest thing you can conceive of but as
you move towards it you transform and
then and your conceptualization of
what's the highest shifts as you
transform so you're aiming at the
highest thing but but your perhaps your
ability to conceptualize what's the
highest thing develops as you move
towards it and so but what that means in
practice is that you do take detours
because you aim at something but your
aim is off and you move towards it and
then you get to a point where you can
correct your aim and so it's not like
you've made a mistake exactly it's
you're farther ahead than you were and
you've corrected your aim but your aim
wasn't you weren't aiming at exactly the
right thing to begin with and so now go
ahead well maybe that's what's happening
to Abraham is that you know you could
almost say I don't know that Ishmael is
a
practice run something like that well so
all right so then you were going to
Matthew you were going to say something
about that oh yeah I was going to say
that exile in the Bible there's always a
reason for it but it's not necessarily a
logical reason it's it's just like what
you described you think you know
something you think you'd know what
you're aiming at you think you know what
you want you think you know what you're
doing something happens that you didn't
plan and that doesn't look like it's
part of what you were aiming it makes
you take a detour well this this side is
all about detours it's all about turning
around you don't know where you're going
you're lost so but in the end if it
brings about something that maybe you
weren't even aiming at in the first
place yeah but might be better than what
you were in in the first place so it's
not all bad so I think that's the idea
the idea of the whole idea of exile is
that there it renews your plans right
if you don't die yeah if you don't that
ha ha ha ha yeah even if you do die for
New York life well yeah ok ok so now ok
so now the next thing that happens is
that the strangers come to visit Abraham
and he treats them hospitably and so now
we might say that that's an indication
of his increasing alignment with the
good maybe that's one way of thinking
about it because he does right by the
stranger and one of the consequences of
that is that the angels I guess we find
out that they're angels
tell him that Sarah is going to give
birth to someone and Abraham finds that
very difficult to believe it Sarah finds
it so difficult to believe that she
actually laughs about it she overhears
it she laughs about it but but he he has
the strangers he feeds them and he has
them wash their feet if I remember
correctly and
anyways he treats them hospitably it
well and there's a blessing as a
consequence of that and that's something
we talked about a fair bit Jonathan when
we were talking about Tom the thing
doesn't fit in categories yeah the
stranger yeah which is that invitation
to chaos as well that you were talking
about Matthew because the stranger is
well the thing that you can be
subjugated to but also something that
will bring something new and potentially
disruptive but also potentially
beneficial and so then the idea there is
whether or not the stranger is
disruptive or beneficial depends to a
large degree on how you treat the
stranger and that's that strikes me as
very very possible I mean that's the one
thing that that's one of the things that
has really entered my imagination as a
clinician know if you're approached by
someone who's very in chaos the
consequence of that is very dependent on
how you interact with them because it
can go any way and they're not really in
control because there's so chaotic and
so if you're careful and awake you can
keep things moving in the proper
direction and maybe even benefit from it
and that's kind of like the idea of Noah
walking with God because one of the
reasons that Noah gets through the flood
is because he's oriented properly he's
walking with God and so you could say
that
exile can it's something like exile can
expand you if you stay properly oriented
while you're in exile it can fix it can
fix your mistakes that's part of it it
cleans you it renews you because you
make mistakes
yeah and they become part of you and if
you're just stuck with your mistakes
you're rigid about your own mistakes you
need something outer to something that
you don't know something that you don't
understand the clean you're like takes
away
yeah well that's like the gold the
dragon hordes with a virgin that the
dragon hordes right it's it's if the
dragon represents that chaotic would say
exile state the drag or the gold and the
and the virgin both represent that which
can be
assimilated as a consequence of being in
that situation the funny thing is is in
the hero myths going into exile on
purpose works way better than going into
exile accidentally yeah so that's an
interesting thing so okay okay so now
well can I say something about the part
you were describing the whole story of
Abraham if you look at the big picture
it's really about progressive
progressively knowing something so it
starts with just the voice okay oh god
go here doesn't mean much goes there
then it becomes a little more precise I
will give you this land but is more
specific and then as the further he goes
the more it becomes explicit what's
going to happen so I'll give you a son
when I don't know someday
it doesn't say later on it becomes more
and more explicit okay and he says like
in the party were talking about he says
three men come these are angels as it
becomes clear later so this is God right
pod sending his message in a clear
manner and it's more right specific than
before he says this time next year you
will have it's okay so okay so a couple
of things about that
so yes one of the things that see one of
the ways that I've conceptualized the
relationship between the Old Testament
and the New Testament and I this is kind
of a classic Christian conceptualization
I think and it's also it's also
analogous to what happens to Moses
because Moses doesn't get to the
promised land so there's this idea
Christian idea that the reason that
Moses can't get to the promised land is
because he only represents the law now
but then I thought about that I thought
well one of the I've got to say about
four stories at the same time here to
man to get the bill as I'm right so the
first is it's not so easy to speak the
truth but it's fairly easy to stop lying
and so as you stop lying you get better
you get to approximate speaking the
truth but the way you start isn't by
speaking the truth the way you start is
by
stopping line and then a lot of the
rules in the Old Testament are
prohibitions here's a bunch of things
you shouldn't do that you might be
inclined to do and so the idea there
would be if you stop doing all the
things you know you shouldn't do then
you can your head clears up enough so
you can start to see the things that you
should do and so then in the Abrahamic
story maybe it's something like this
you said you implied Matthew that
Abraham had originally follows something
like a vague and he'll defined whim but
he has enough faith to move forward
despite the fact that it's vague and
ill-defined and then as a consequence of
moving forward it becomes more and more
concretize dand and differentiated and
clear okay that's right man because
that's you know it's funny because the
future authoring program we've developed
is sort of predicated on that idea the
first thing you do is wander around in a
kind of confused days trying to find a
direction of orientation and then you
clarify that and partly you do that by
continuing to think about it but you
also clarify it by acting on it okay
yeah and that's the idea these three men
that come visit him
there's a reason whether it's three okay
it's because it's it's trying to express
the idea that it's more expressed it's
more explicit it's not just the seed
anymore it's like it's like a branch
okay you've got up here you've got
something that looks like a branch it's
branching out into a more concrete thing
and at first it's just a voice then its
division then it's actual people okay
Shay okay okay
so here's another idea so
let's say if you're beginning to develop
morality you you behave so that the
people who share your morality can get
along with you
that means you follow the rules but if
you're dealing with strangers it's a
different issue because they aren't part
of your morality and so the question
then is how do you act properly when
you're not in the domain of your
morality and I always thought about that
as a meta moral domain and it seems to
me that it's the domain that Christ
occupies because he's he's like the
mediator between morality
he's in no man's land and is a mediator
between morality Xand and if you're if
you're if you've oriented yourself
properly then you even know how to act
with there aren't any rules and that's
why Abraham can act properly in
relationship to the strangers he's awake
enough so that when the strangers show
up shows up he can pay attention to the
way they're acting and can act
spontaneously as a consequence of paying
attention and things go well and so the
strangers aren't hostile they don't kill
him they don't take his wife they don't
do any of the terrible things that
strangers could do and he gets a
blessing as a consequence of it that
seemed reasonable
it is but we have to understand that
these strangers are come from heaven in
the sense that they've bringing a
message they're not just random
strangers very they're sent well maybe
he would have acted the same way with
strangers that wasn't sent and that's
the whole point he doesn't know that's
right we act in a way that allows for
that yeah yeah for the one that accent
okay here is Eve okay so that's very
interesting too because one of the
things that I think you see happening as
a consequence of the transition from the
Old Testament to the New Testament is
that part of Christ's message is to act
in exactly that way is to act in a
manner that allows for the possibility
of the emergence of the good that's
something like that's something like
what would you describe as a description
of the necessity of faith and you know
like let's say you stretch out your hand
to someone in trust
should be naive but it's a precondition
for good things happening AG if you're
distrustful and you have every reason to
be because people are full of snakes if
you're distrustful you foreclose the
opportunity for cooperative progress
instantly you might protect yourself
against being bitten now net so so there
is a dramatic relationship between the
manner in which you open yourself up to
the world and the way the world treats
you and one of the things that seems to
be really emphasized it's more implicit
in the Old Testament more explicit the
New Testament is that the more you open
yourself up to the possibility that good
things will happen and that's partly by
accepting your vulnerability as far as I
can tell the higher the probability is
that good things will in fact happen
yeah I mean I would definitely say that
in the story of Abraham the like we were
kind of flirting around that idea before
is that the reason why he was able to to
receive them as these angels that they
were able to manifest themselves as
these angels was because he was willing
to host them properly eat he like it's
as if his family just like Sarah like
Sarah is is he was the right ground for
that manifestation at that time right
well yeah I would say that they wouldn't
have been angels if he wouldn't have
treated them properly well he might have
been here but they might have done they
might have done what they did in Sodom
and Gomorrah like that's the whole thing
okay so now I want to switch I want to
flip the head a little bit this is
really what I this is I think of all the
things I wanted to discuss with you guys
I think this is the one that's most
crucial because okay so now we're in
let's say we're in Sodom with the with
the angels and we're in the part of the
story where the townspeople have Sodom
gather around the house and they tell
law and unless he throws out the
strangers so that they can be raped
well the townspeople demand that and
then law it offers them his daughters
which seems like a hell of a thing to do
it's like the sacrifice of Isaac to some
degree
what it looks like to me because he's
willing to sacrifice his daughters to
protect the strangers now okay so that's
a morally let's call that a morally
ambiguous element of the story but then
the townspeople reject out and they tell
they basically tell him that he has no
right or power to bargain and that not
only are they going to take his
daughters but they're also going to take
the stranger's so it doesn't work but
you know to modern sensibility the
offering of his daughters is a
reprehensible thing but it seems to be
that in the context of the story it's an
indication of how hard Lotte is trying
to treat the strangers properly in a
place where that's essentially
impossible yes that's the whole point of
that story that place is impossible
that's the whole point I think what he
just said okay there's no way out of it
right Leonard Cohen said something about
that he said there's he had a line that
I remember quite well he said there's no
decent place to stand in the massacre
and what that seems to mean is that
something it's something like you can
get into a place where that's made of
such a compound of errors and deceit and
catastrophe that no matter which way you
turn there is no good yeah
I've seen people like that my clinical
practice there's there's no good there's
no good alternative everything is sin
that's that's a good way of no matter
which way you shake your you're not
going to hit the mark because you're not
somewhere where the mark can be hit okay
now I've been trying to think about the
story of Sodom and Gomorrah in
relationship to modern sexual confusion
so this is what I see happening on the
social justice front let's say on the
one hand since the 1960's and probably
has a consequence of the birth control
pill but other factors as well there's
been tremendous stress placed on sexual
liberation and so there's this idea that
I think is associated in large part
right now with the radical left of total
sexual freedom but at the same time
there's increasing emphasis from exactly
the same sources on restricting sexual
interaction so you see this in the
campuses for example where increasingly
particularly heterosexual contact is
regulated by a doctrine that says you
have to get spoken permission for every
move in the mating process and so you
see and I know I'm not expressing myself
very well but there seems to be in our
current culture there seems to be
massive sexual confusion it's it's some
weird combination of extreme libertinism
and extreme authoritarianism part of
what's happening happening and is that
sex impulse of sexual gratification
trumps everything it's something like
that I mean I know there's more to
what's going on inside of the knob but
there's certainly that and so well I'm
trying to figure out what to say about
that tonight because well there's
there's a lesson in there the lesson is
something like don't let sexuality
don't let impulse and sexuality get the
upper hand it's something like that or
all hell will break loose which I
actually happen to agree with so one of
the things that we haven't been able to
talk about in our culture I think is
let's take the idea the phenomenon of
AIDS like AIDS mutated to take advantage
of promiscuous sexuality and that's just
nothing you never hear that publicized
you know people had associated AIDS with
homosexuality and there was a reason for
that because it's much more easily
transmitted as a consequence of
homosexual sex than heterosexual sex
because the anus is a much more delicate
physiological structure it's not as
robust and it can be eat much more
easily damaged and and and with with
disease resulting as a consequence but
it isn't only the matter of sexual
action that's the issue it's also the
fact that promiscuity provided the
evolutionary platform for the AIDS virus
to mutate into a very into the form that
it finally took and it was only through
the skin by the skin of our teeth that
we escaped a total izing plague you know
had that emerged 100 years ago
god only knows how many people would
have died AIDS was unbelievably fatal so
I know that's a mishmash of ideas and
I'm not exactly sure how to see my way
clear through it but there is a clear
warning in that story about about
something about to do with with with
sexual iniquity in in the Bible that
sexuality has two two poles that define
it and it's pretty clear one one side is
reproduction and the other side is we
could let's say recreation okay so so
those are the two folds of sexuality in
a normal world so it's not just for
reproduction and it's not just for
recreation it's both like that was the
idea I mean I mean actual idea now if
you if there's a balance there and you
know that should be have if you lose
this balance and it becomes just about
reproduction that's a problem if it
becomes just about recreation that's
another problem you know okay it's not
that complicated really but it's so
politically incorrect to talk about
these things a little bit obvious well
that nobody cares you talk about it
the thing is is that the most difficult
things to talk about are the things that
are obvious because when they're obvious
you don't have to talk about them and so
then when people start to question the
obvious you don't know what to say yes I
guess so for example we would I I'm
thinking about the [ __ ] walks you know
and so women go out and they dress very
provocatively and and they go out and
manifest their right to be as
provocative as they possibly can be
without being interfered with and I have
some sympathy for that perspective
because it seems to me appropriate for
women to be the final arbiters in sexual
contact but on the other hand it also
it's that whole exercise is blind to the
fact that clothing for example has
communicative intent and that people
broadcast their invitation to sexual
congress in a million ways subtle and
not-so-subtle
and you can't just say I have the right
to broadcast myself in any manner
possible and be completely beat what
completely immune from the consequences
there's something wrong with that and
with regards to basic sexual morality
you know I've read things about like
slut-shaming is that the more radical
feminist types for example claim that
women shouldn't be held responsible for
their sexual behavior in some sense
shouldn't be held against them how many
men they've slept with etc but then I
think well you never recommend to
someone that they lay down naked on the
on the side of the street with their
legs spread and invite anybody who walks
by to partake of the opportunity
everyone would regard that as
inappropriate I think without question
and so what that indicates is that some
degree of sexual propriety is both
normative and ethical and then of course
you can start asking yourself about what
that degree of social sexual propriety
should be and it does have something to
do with getting the balance between
reproduction and recreation right okay
but the thing even in the Bible there's
there's the two aspects some stories are
about just this aspect and there are the
most strange stories in the Bible for
example the story of Tamar is one of
those so I don't know if you're familiar
with that story but stuff it's in that
it's intercut with the story of Joseph
okay in Egypt and it's essentially it
says that Judah has children with some
woman and I think it's a stranger it
doesn't necessarily say so but it seems
like that's what it is
and then the sons die off and then
there's this woman called Tamar and she
disguises herself as a prostitute great
and she has a kid with Judah himself so
all the simple jurors heard that shorty
elements of his clothing yes demonstrate
as a as a bribe yes essentially she
wants to indicate later that he's the
one who slept with her yeah yeah yeah so
that story is about then is that the
need for the recreated part of sexuality
it's all about that symbolism it's all
about the seat it's all about incest
it's all about that and the idea is it's
to raise the dead okay it's not clear in
the story but if you understand the
imagery that's what it's about it's
about regressing back to an error that
was made okay and raising the dead so I
want to get into it but just the idea
that in the Bible there's folks
- there's reproduction and there's
recreation and the recreation is renewal
there's the original sexuality is about
renewal - but that aspect of the
symbolism is is pretty I don't want to
say obscure because it's actually right
there if you can see it but it's it's
strange I'll say it like that
it's a strange okay okay so now another
element of this might be the fact that
in modern identity politics sexual
choice is a canonical identifier and
that also seems to me to be something
wrong about that like one of the things
I've seen happening in Toronto I'm sure
it's the same in Montreal is that and
I'm going to do this awkwardly I'm going
to put this awkwardly because I haven't
been able to sort through it properly
Pride Week Pride Day has turned into
Pride Week and that's turned into Pride
Month and I think that seems to me to be
pushing against some kind of limit
because the first question that I have
is like I was reading this book the
other day by a friend of mine from
Ottawa who's a gay conservative and he
said he had a lot harder time coming out
as a conservative than he had as coming
out as gay and he talked about the
degree to which homosexuals were
persecuted in Canada before say the
1980s and it's quite it makes quite
parce reading let's say and so-and-so
fair enough to the to the civil rights
movement let's say it that has brought
homosexuality into the norm or that into
the mainstream maybe that's one way of
thinking about it but that conversation
still has a tremendous amount of
development that's necessary because I
don't understand exactly it isn't
obvious to me what integration into the
mainstream precisely means because a lot
there's been a lot of talk so far about
respecting the rights of gay people but
very little talk about what the
accompanying responsibilities might be
that actually seems to me to be a
problem and I mean I just had a letter
from from gay guy who is being wrestling
with this because he's not sure how to
be gay and to be ethical at the same
time you know because he sees part of
normative behavior as taking wife and
having children and not and can see the
value in that but that's certainly not
the direction of his proclivity and so
we wrote wrote to me asking me what he
should do and you know I don't have an
answer for that I don't know what the
answer to that is but I know that it
might be something that would be worth
talking about and then it's part of this
current confusion about sexual identity
and sexual pleasure and and well even
gender identity for that matter so all
right so your idea was well the balance
between recreation and reproduction had
gone was completely absent in Sodom it
was all recreation it was all instant
gratification and impulse yeah and
that's why it's put in contests with the
Abraham bit because it's the same Angels
know in that case he says you'll have a
son
this time next year so it's the
reproduction part is there but when he
gets to the bottom it's not there
anymore
it's only the recreation part okay yeah
so there goes they're meant to be
contested those two swords actually
in the story of Abraham it's pretty
clear he goes um I don't know if this
will make sense because it when the
angels come it says um he washes their
feet and then he feasts them okay that's
actually the recreation and reproduction
part that's not a sense of sexuality but
it's in terms of meaning the renewal the
washing of the feet is the recreation
part the renewals or restarting and the
feeding is the reproduction part that's
not the sexual way but when you feed
something food and it eats it and
integrate it integrates it correctly
that's like a reproduction of your
identity or you're staying yourself
you're reproducing yourself so when you
eat food that's what you're doing not
like I said not in a sexual way but it
has exactly the same meaning if you eat
something that you can integrate
correctly you're like reproducing your
pattern it's like the correct version of
yourself
and then the other side the washing is
that like is that mental flood yeah look
it's a mini flood right it also isn't
accessible right it's a controlled one
you're washing the dust off your the
roads dust off your feet it means that
you're you're passing from one mode of
being into another because you're you're
cleaning off the debris of the past it's
something like that and then it's about
renewal next yeah okay so you have to
see that when when when Matthew is
talking about the idea of recreation you
have to understand that recreation and
rest are basically the same thing right
let's basically have the same meaning
it's sleeping resting recreation are all
guides that bring you into renewal okay
all right dying even dying that's what
dying is it's this passing into another
state letting something else have a
chance that's what time is it I mean